[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing another theory within the
greater wizarding world
that's right i'm excited to say that
today's video is another theory
regarding the recently released trailer
for the upcoming film fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore while there
are a lot of great theories that have
come about from the trailer many of them
rightfully so focus on imagined or
suspected events that will take place in
the film set to be released this spring
today's theory however is more an
analysis of what the presentation of a
certain character
may say about who he is and who he will
become within the fantastic beasts
franchise as you've likely deduced from
the title of this video i'm of course
speaking of credence barebone allegedly
born aurelius dumbledore brother to
albus dumbledore that is if the word of
gelat grindelwald can be trusted
and so if you've watched the secrets of
dumbledore trailer which i assume all of
you have then you've likely noticed that
credence seems to have gotten a new look
since the last couple of films that is
in both fantastic beasts and where to
find them and fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald credence sports
two distinctively cropped haircuts which
in themselves are actually quite
different from one another in the first
film credence has a rather unflattering
bowl cut which was laughed at on the
internet through various memes and alike
poor bloke in any case it can be assumed
that married lou barebone gave him this
extremely unattractive cut which he then
sheds in the second movie in favor of an
even shorter thankfully plainer and
let's be honest more presentable haircut
this transition between the two looks
was likely to signify the passage of
time that took place between the two
films and the fact that mary lou is no
longer alive and in control of his hair
or his life for that matter in the
second film
so in a way his change in hairstyle can
be viewed as a representation of him
breaking free from mary lou and her
mental and physical abuse
that said as you'll know from the new
trailer credence's hair has since gone
through another more dramatic transition
as it's now down to his shoulders in
length now other than the fact that the
character of credence or perhaps the
actor who portrays credence as ramilla
may simply like having longer hair what
could this change in style mean well as
many fans have commented credence's new
look is rather reminiscent of another
harry potter character known for his
shoulder length raven locks
severus snape
in fact i've actually seen many a query
wondering if credence barebone could in
fact be related to severus rather than
albus dumbledore as grindelwald claims
however there is lots of evidence
throughout the larger wizarding world
and harry potter universe to disprove
this theory
so i can't say that i believe there is
substance to there being any relation
between credence and snape other than a
passing resemblance and the same
haircuts but i must admit that i do
believe the similarities in their
appearance may have been created on
purpose
here's why
one of the many wonderful things about
the harry potter series is the depth of
the characters witches and wizards were
often presented as having multiple
facets of humanity that make them more
relatable as well humans albeit with
magical abilities albus dumbledore is of
course a wonderful example of this he is
most often portrayed as a great hero and
mentor within the series
but as we all know he wasn't always so
good or on the right side
as you may recall growing up albus had a
close relationship with gelat
grindelwald and shared many of his
fanatical anti-muggle sentiments there's
also lots to suggest that perhaps he
doesn't always make the right decision
for instance many fans and harry potter
characters fiercely believe that he
should have shared what he knew about
harry's inevitable self-sacrifice with
harry himself snape included
but alas i digress
severus snape is of course another great
example of a complex harry potter
character with many layers throughout
many of the harry potter novels and
films he is indeed depicted as a villain
but as we progress through the series
lots about snape and his motives are
uncovered revealing that he was actually
a decent person a wizard who was in love
with the good and moral witch harry's
mother lily evans who simply wanted to
belong and was lured to the power and
camaraderie of the dark arts but who
ultimately chose to help those who
opposed lord voldemort though i suppose
you could say that all the good he did
was in the name of his own self-interest
that is his love for lily but good he
did do regardless of his motives
so with all that in mind it would seem
that severus snape was an anti-hero
within harry potter that is a
protagonist or central character who
lacks certain conventional heroic
qualities such as morality and honesty
and so i would say that in a similar way
credence barebone seems to have been set
up to be the anti-hero of the fantastic
beasts series
he is not by nature an evil person his
existence as an obscurial is completely
circumstantial
that is his magic was repressed due to
mary lou barebone's abuse towards him
throughout his upbringing
which resulted in the creation of a dark
parasitical magical force otherwise
known as an obscurus
so although credence harbors this
obscurus which is incredibly destructive
when released it would seem that
credence never intentionally releases
its dark magical force it only comes
about when he loses control of his
emotions or feels extreme distress
so again he isn't wreaking havoc or
bringing about destruction with evil
intentions he seems to just be a young
man who longs to understand who he is
to belong somewhere discover where he
came from
hugh grindelwald
either because he believes that credence
is actually a member of the dumbledore
family or because he simply wants to
take advantage of his magical power
grindelwald has spent the better part of
the last two fantastic beasts movies
trying to persuade credence to join his
cause it would seem that grindelwald has
done so with the intention of having
credence eventually challenge albus if
credence is a dumbledore he may be the
only one strong enough to defeat his
brother aside from grindelwald who has
taken part in a blood pact with albus
and likely can't jewel him himself
so after guiding credence through
various discoveries throughout the films
by the end of the crimes of grindelwald
gelet has successfully seduced credence
into joining him
as it all unfolds it appears as though
credence feels he's left with little
choice but to go with grindelwald
if he ever wants to belong
and although he seems to quite willingly
join grindelwald in that ring of bright
blue fire at the end of the second film
thanks to queenie goldstein's legitimacy
abilities we know that credence isn't
completely convinced that he's made the
right decision in following grindelwald
and his acolytes as she reveals to gelet
in the final scene of the movie
you need to be careful he's not sure he
made the right choice be very gentle
with him
so we have a young powerful wizard who's
choosing a path filled with dark magic
in an effort to belong somewhere and yet
he remains hesitant as to whether it was
the right thing to do
leaving valued relationships with those
such as nagini behind
remind you of anyone why yes i do
believe that sounds an awful lot like
our dear severus snape for this reason i
wouldn't be surprised if eventually
credence makes a choice or two that's
moral and good in nature
aligning himself with those who oppose
grindelwald
making him the anti-hero of the series
in the same way snape was for harry
potter
perhaps if it serves his interests he
will even fully switch sides and fight
alongside his friend and former ally
nagini and his alleged brother albus in
order to defeat grindelwald i suppose
we'll have to wait until april or longer
to find out
so there you have it zephyrus snape and
credence barebone may not be related in
the familial sense but i sure do believe
that their physical similarities offer
clues into the character development and
story arc of credence in the fantastic
beasts series
what do you think is this way too
far-fetched for you do you even see
resemblance between snape and credence
perhaps you just think that ezra miller
likes wearing his hair long
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe to
the channel until next time you don't
want me as your enemy
[Music]
you